hello welcome to this video raelia my
opponent is there nope ok let's go for
my I really have to check my statistics
that one's probably have never ever
played a draw with the same issue maybe
some Perpetual's or so but yeah it's
just such a sharp opening yeah that's
one of the older ways to better this
back to what Vinick kappa blanca 1936
since 1936 i think it is 38 something
like that
yeah going for an e for you for break
here in the center got some experience
with those position this is why I played
it quite quickly IDs Bishop b2 and then
a form currently if I it's not possible
because of that week d4 pawn okay that
is normally a huge strategic mistake and
kind of okay it's not worried at all I
Bishop g5 was in strong I have to slow
down I mean I really have to if they
play such rubbish I have to think for a
moment and then total refuted there's
really bad am Bishop g5 was a lot
stronger a lot stronger I mean this is
still terrible for black but I could
have played the other line and it would
have been more convincing absolutely now
I'm winning the exchange em at least
okay so i think i take here first i came
i think i can take on wait let's check
let's check this quickly ago Bishop e3
no that doesn't work at all I have to
shove f2 at the end so I can't do this
first and then take and click one of the
rooks an IDE 5d takes d5 d 4 i've got
bishop f2 doesn't work at all now see
for it's just a strategic nightmare that
move ok so now i can trade Queens and
probably have to anyway so let's do that
and then grab grab in the exchange and
okay at the moment I don't have to take
it right away but I wonder if there's
some point in delaying that Luke see one
is an interesting move can so that he
cannot move the night damn what is this
move actually against that 94 wait 94 94
group chick see 892 it's actually
playable amazing um so
and I just want to ever have something
that is more precise them than just
grabbing only eight Roxy 194 is kind of
a miracle move but if it works it works
again so let's grab and so let's do this
night 85 this Bishop I yep got Bishop t2
and that should be quite clear rupee aid
was stronger I will beat was probably
the same thing okay that was his idea
but i think i can get this now
it's a pin now come on black resigns
yeah now the thing is the c-4 it's just
not a play will move I think it's just
that that just not good at all it gives
me I don't know I don't get it why the
play that that kind of move because it's
it's well known since like 19 25 or so
1930 that you cannot do this with the
form unless you have a super clear quick
counter play and black doesn't have any
so before and here i just i went if I've
maybe it's the best movie I played I
played it too quickly because I wanted
to just punish that that stuff but I
should have at least considered Bishop
g5 i'm not sure if it is really stronger
but this threat is pretty substantial
okay the engine gives h6 maybe five is
better actually what i did but i mean
this is pretty awful the night coming to
d6 yeah yeah that said should work at
all takes Teague's yeah but should be
three i think is important if I check
here he's got 94 so this and now we
cannot do anything like that because i
have this move what's still important to
have is this I took it yeah I mean this
would have been nice but he's got this
trick I just took it and then look here
I was thinking this but I think it does
win as well can I do this night see four
we'll be three
okay that's not entirely clear now okay
that should win for why but it's not
entirely clear and the engine wants to
do this this this here and though just
back yeah this is better of course
intending but should be one that's good
technical play yeah Miriam so this is
the best probably here here and now this
is important yeah yeah very important
actually that I can't take here because
of the back rank now just this move is
strong I'm getting a second point okay
next wasn't that easy technically the
movie for something that black has to be
very very cautious about because it
gives white free rein in the center it
is his play it takes a few moves until
it is substantial and I'm already
breaking through in the center if five I
just wonder maybe Bishop g5 is better I
don't know I really don't know the
engine and gives this him you know Ruby
one funny enough or that's not
convincing I think this is better what I
did is better I mean black can try to
not lose the exchange with some move
rookie six for example it's also not
entirely clear
yeah it's not clear at all maybe that
isn't so bad I mean c4 usually is just
utter rubbish and maybe here it is not
one of the worst instance of that still
Bishop g5 I don't know and this is also
line that the engine is giving just
taking that porn and but that is not too
convincing I think now okay maybe it
wasn't complete completely bad see for
this particular moment but in general
i'm very skeptical about this this kind
of advanced in this structure okay
thanks for watching